Hang on. Was muted the whole time,
wasn't I?
Anyways, um we should be live here.
Cool.
Uh let's update this.
So, let's let's talk about what we're
doing here. Um, and a little bit about
what I've been up to and where I've been
and uh what we're doing in the next few
days. So, I've had some client stuff to
work on, but I've also just had a whole
bunch of kind of boring refactoring work
to do and um it just wouldn't have been
particularly fun or interesting or
whatever to stream. So, haven't been
streaming for the last bit. a couple
other things going on. But I figured I'd
give a little bit of an update on where
we're at today and uh do a little bit of
the work live since we have something
sort of fun. First of all, oops.
All right. Something is wrong. Oh, cuz
net hack CU is in source. Okay. Okay.
So, subtract 1,800 lines from this and
uh we're at about 12k lines.
12.1 12.2k lines. So, that's like minus
3,000 lines from the source. Obviously,
I have net hack stuff to deal with. This
is not going to live here either way.
Um, so puffer core
that puffer core is under 6K lines.
Proteins under 2K.
pretty nice.
And then there are a few things I have
to clean up still.
And what's going on here is Finn has
some really nice net hack results.
I'm not going to share all the graphs
and stuff. I'm going to let him be able
to do his work on blogs and stuff.
Um I'm going to let him do his work on
blogs because this is all like this is
all from him.
But I think I want to play around with
uh with this code a little bit
and
see if I can find any like easy fixes.
So, first of all, let me just get rid of
this experiment. This didn't work.
We can launch this except also hang on.
And he told me that I have to rebuild
Apparently, this has a crash fix in it.
Okay, so we'll let this run.
This is async mode.
We'll see how this goes. I believe this
is about a 20 minute run.
And uh we're going to look at some stuff
in the meantime.
but we will leave that be for now. Let's
see what he was sweeping.
Just rewards.
Those are a lot of rewards to sweep
jointly with the config is the only
thing that I would notice.
So, I mean, this is getting into the
realm of like too tough for protein
potentially.
First of all, this is going to be
nondeterministic.
looks like this is a part of the
existing architecture.
And no wonder Finn's having trouble with
this. Like, this is basically not even
human editable. This is all LLM code.
We'll do We have a couple different
layers to look at here.
a couple different layers.
I'm going to want to look at
my mic working. I think it is right. Let
me just check Twitch.
Uh, hang on.
Should be good.
Right. Yep. Okay.
This possibly not as bad.
Okay. Actually here.
I messed with his demo a little bit to
make it um semicontrollable,
but I haven't messed with anything else
much yet.
What is net hack? Net hack is grand
challenge for AI.
Very awesome env. I've wanted to do
something with this for years. I put
Finn on the project and he's gotten some
very nice results. So, um, he's kind of
gotten to himself to a spot where it's
kind of tough to make progress. So, I'm
seeing if I can make any, uh, if I can
sort of unblock him a little bit.
First of all, I don't like the ordering
of this
and it's preference. I want to put this
here.
I don't know what it is with like codecs
and like trying to skip all these
language models and trying to skip
like
like why wouldn't you just do this,
right?
Come on.
I think we're chill with everything
else.
This is actually fairly Simple.
I actually don't think I want this here
at all. I think I want
if anything
What do we think about this?
Anything else that we need?
Yeah,
we do need max depth as well.
Take this here.
Important to have your logs in a way
that it's easy to review them.
Trying to give this the attention it
deserves.
I actually, it's funny. As soon as I hop
on stream with a like a new project like
this, I can focus way better.
Okay, this is Yeah, we can delete all
this [ __ ]
Oh, no. Wait, we can't. Okay, because it
compiled separate I think
I still don't think we should need that.
We'll figure it out.
Okay, so his action space is very odd
for sure.
I'm very intentionally um resisting the
urge to like immediately start [ __ ]
with this with Grock or whatever cuz
even though a good chunk of this I know
is like vibe Cody crap, I also know Finn
has put a lot of manual effort into
this. So I want to at least to the
extent that is possible with the current
code quality figure out what is uh
what's going on.
This is
H. Okay.
This is going to be joined with the uh
the architecture
finally. Yeah, cred. I've just been I've
kind of just been refactoring some
stuff. I've had some client work as
well. Um, I have some nice progress to
share. We're down to just over 12k lines
in the core of puffer now. It's good
progress. We also have async training,
which is very fast.
We have the first sub 1 second breakout
solve ever.
Fancy man.
Uh, this seems like is this just async?
If async hurts a lot, we'll just
consider it experimental and do this.
Ben, how's it going, man? I'm looking
through all the code.
It's still quite a lot of code. A lot of
it is kind of ged as well. Like tons and
tons of stuff is just one lined that
shouldn't be. So, it's actually probably
almost twice this length unguled.
I was looking through.
It's not reward hacking exits anymore.
What?
All right, Finn. Um, I definitely need
to understand what net this is. Is this
like a straight port of the like the
competition baseline to CUDA C? Like
there's like an 1800 line CUDA file.
we have an 1800 line CUDA file here with
the model.
This is fine.
This is probably at least a thousand
lines unulfed.
The macros looked fine. Uh I have
vaguely have some idea of what this is
and then I messed with the bindings
files vibe coded from scratch.
Okay. But what is it of like what is the
network?
It's also not deterministic. I'm pretty
sure
though we have bigger problems to deal
with than that.
That checks Easy thing to do is to go
implement the network in torch and then
get it to like you can port and check
versus that
though sometimes torch numeric are
screwy.
There's just a lot of stuff in there,
man. Like, do you have something that
tells me where like what the
architecture is?
I've gotten like high 4,000 so far score
out of it on 5C.
Uh, did you PR that test? I don't have
Oh, you know what? You probably didn't.
And I probably didn't pull it. Hang on.
Cuz I'm on 5C.
But like what where does this
architecture come from? fan.
1D CNN would be a um
Isn't that the same thing?
Well, almost.
It's tough to ablate when you have this
much noise run to run.
We'll see if we can get some perf first
of all.
are um are the only is the only action
with a ton of
wait there are several actions that take
many turns, right? That are baked in.
What about I see it doing movement
macros though.
So I did Hang on.
Okay. So I I modified this a little bit
so that I can control when it steps.
Look at that. That was one step.
That's three.
It just went
actually. How does it even do that?
Yeah, exactly. Huh. Right.
Fortress definitely not as good of a
benchmark for AI.
Yeah. So, Finn, this exact thing, I see
it moved this way all the time. I
thought that you did this intentionally.
Why not? Because Dwarf Fortress doesn't
really have concrete goals. Like, you
could come up with some, I guess,
but Net Hack is nice and that it does
have like a big overarching goal with
lots of things you can work towards.
Yes, it's fine.
I guess this one's probably not as slow
at least.
It has an interesting biasing effect
with credit assignment.
Search macro.
Search macro I don't like
cuz look at this. So 500 searches
times 20 actions that's 2,000
things. So that right there that's half
of your compute on the end. Half of this
number is searches.
The one below.
Oh.
Uh, is there a thing about like sending
individual keys being
is there like a weird thing with sending
keys one at a time
this the next run. I bet you it's
faster.
So, we get down to 170. Was it 150 to
170k SPS?
I bet you this gets us a lot of our
compute back.
Explain briefly what I'm doing.
I am uh reviewing and trying stuff on
top of Finn's
net hack binding that lets us run
Puffer's ultra high performance
reinforcement learning on Net Hack.
And I'm seeing if we can speed stuff up.
I'm seeing if I find any obvious
oversightes and I'm generally seeing if
I can like create some new ways that uh
Finn can make more progress on this end.
I will say Finn that the new async stuff
that we have is very interesting for
this though not fully tested.
Reason for running only 512 ms on net
hack. Uh at least currently it's very
slow.
So typically when the env is slow you
end up um leaning in the direction of
fewer ends and fewer samples per batch
so that you get more out of each chunk
of on policy data
and uh sweep will typically find that
for you automatically as well. I don't
know if you included the number of MS in
the sweep pin.
As you can see, at least with this
version, we're hard bottlenecked though
by the end
cash.
Wait, what do you mean cash?
Where's this end key thing?
No, off policy is kind of just garbage
from what I've seen.
It's just really [ __ ] bad.
I think in general um was a mistake. Now
you can have very slightly off policy
stuff for high throughput,
but the motive is pretty different
there.
Learn and adapt fast like humans.
Humans are not tabularasa.
You don't need you b you don't need to
make AI work like humans.
In fact, in many ways, humans are really
[ __ ] stupid.
And uh one of the cool things with RL is
you can be superhuman in many ways.
Like the amount of data that you can
process with these networks is just a
bit like it's just absurd.
Um, you know, we go through more data
than any of the AI labs do
just with our little tiny one machine
experiments.
Oh, this is a decent run here, Finn. At
least this is still with the search 20
on. This is like four to 5k
and this looks decent.
What would h it would just completely
fail.
What? What do you mean like
hello LLM? Please just like fix the
field of reinforcement learning.
What?
It's not cuz there's no training on it.
Like,
they're just they're not good. I I don't
know what to tell you.
Like, why aren't LLMs doing every job in
the world currently?
Like we use LLMs as tools for various
bits of what we do.
Like there's nowhere near being able to
do all this though.
We train it enough.
I mean, that's kind of the bet that the
labs are making, but there's I mean,
that's just like a Hail Mary, whatever.
They're still very much making the same
stupid mistakes they were making 3 years
ago.
That's also like a there's just no
thought put into that whatsoever.
bounces around a little bit here, Finn,
because it gets to 5K, but then it
doesn't go up to floor six or thing
Hello, welcome. Yeah, so um I would say
in general that fine-tuning the reward
function is like the least valuable
thing you can do. Uh what we typically
do is when we have something that we do
need multiple reward components, we just
make those parameters and then we throw
the weightings of those rewards into a
hyperparameter sweep and then uh the
sweep figures out the reward
coefficients. If you do spend manual
effort on a problem, it's much better to
be thinking about the observation
representations, the action space, and
then very often um any form of
curriculum if needed.
I mean, Raan obviously like and I'm
going to tell you like the type of RL
stuff I'm doing. That's why I'm doing it
because I think it's important.
Yeah. Error. The code bases are really
crap. Um, and it's kind of funny that
you see like, oh, it solved this
mathematical conjecture and that
mathematical conjecture, and then it
just still writes the most ass code
you've ever seen. One of the reasons I
haven't been streaming the last few days
is because I've been spending so much
time just having to refactor all the
code. Like look at this.
So ignore this net hack code and we're
down to about 12.1K lines. 12.2k lines.
Like this is minus 3k lines with the
same. In fact, I've actually added a few
features just minus 3k lines of pure
bloat.
Okay, 4.8k on net hack, right?
And we want to get this dev loop down.
20 minutes is way too long to be waiting
for our experiments.
Oh, this is going to be some name
collision crap. Hang on.
net hack level smaller. You wouldn't
want to.
Yeah, but you really wouldn't like
you really just want the full game but
fast.
5 mil total. Wait, five mil time steps.
That seems very weird.
Hey, Glitzy, welcome.
We're doing some net hack. We have Finn
here as well
who has done all this stuff,
right?
I figured it was going to be like a
stupid spoofed character.
There's another reason I don't stupid
them being dumb.
Wait, I don't think it recompiled, did
it?
Oh, wait. Cuz we don't have the binding
file.
I see.
Well, I don't know, Finn. Has anybody
bothered profiling yet?
convert I it would have to be fast. If
you're doing five mil steps
like the reason that we like Robo Code
right now is we can train on one node.
We can do Robo Code at uh 100 mil SPS.
That's before uh everything else.
100K, 50K. Man, everybody is always
getting me like these 100 200k SPS runs.
Like that's so two versions of puffer
ago.
What do you mean 2x base? Just like uh
double the net size.
Most [sighs] of them. Most of them crit.
I'll make another commit today.
There we are.
Double SPS.
this. Oh, okay. You have Oh, that's
awesome.
It's a very good sign when I go to
suggest a bunch of things and you've
already done them.
some of the code style stuff could use
some work even if it's um automated. I
actually
you can like even though the models
write shitty code by default, you can
get them to write something like
decently passable or at least to
refactor something decently passable
pretty easily.
like the stuff I was doing refactoring
the code, it was just like literally
inline every method that only has one
caller. Like stop gulfing curly braces,
stop adding additional scope with, you
know, curly braces to avoid namespace
collisions. Stop doing macro
conditionals.
Um, remove all shitty defensive checks.
Anytime there's an error check, examine
the caller, see if the error can
actually happen. If not, don't add the
check. if it can see if it can be
restructured so as to make that error
not even a consideration.
Like
a lot of pretty simple things for
writing better code.
I spend so much time on it because
somehow even though I think it's simple
like it's just the language models don't
do it by default. Um, it takes quite a
bit of fiddling
even get them to recent reason
reasonably refactor and there's just a
lot of code that I have to go through
and do that with
warning. What was this? Net hack asked
for something.
Uh, but look at this. You see this 400k
man?
This is 400k at decent score as well.
So, I know it goes down over time, like
once you start using other actions, but
this looks good.
So, I mean, if you were having trouble
with your dev loop, this should cut it
down to 10 minutes, right?
And we'll see what else I can find you
here, obviously,
cuz now the model is going to be uh a
little slow. model shouldn't be taking
up any reasonable amount of time at 400k
SPS only 4 mil per.
Oh, look. Max depth seven. Do you see
this? This is way better already.
I just took the the same thing that you
did, man. I just took the uh I disabled
the search 20.
Now we're at depth seven. We're actually
we're reaching the mines. We're reaching
the deep mines. And we're even getting
to Soaban.
Look at that.
So the problem right Finn is that
because it sees let me this is actually
a teachable thing. So because it can
press the this that key one time and
wait for 20 steps,
it's treating that as a single action,
meaning that if it wants to avoid
getting penalized for gamma discount,
it's kind of incentivized to just like
spam that key so that monsters come to
it very quickly and it can farm rather
than it having to explore.
Sure. If you want to grab me new hypers,
I'll try them out.
I do wonder about the uh the multi-step
actions like even running might be
worse.
Might be better, might be worse to be
determined.
Look at that though.
Yeah, I would ignore score. Like the
score is very [ __ ] This is not a good
indicator.
Yeah. The problem canvert is if you're
just like fulllming the project.
Like that's the way that you actually
make sure the thing is correct.
The issue with those things, it's you
pretty much can only port existing
stuff.
Look at this. So, we're dying in combat
all the time. Now,
we've also shaved almost half of the
time off of this.
I'm going to play around with async, but
I'm going to do async on my own time
without uh No, I'm going to use it this
as like a test to see if async can be
made stable.
This is without the async improvements.
Async will make training much faster
cuz async basically will run the GPU for
the 42% of the time you're spending on
the N.
This is so unbelievably awesome though.
Been excited for Async. If you want to
read about it, it's actually quite
accessible. It's just uh it's exactly
costas cleanba architecture.
It's exactly one uh one epoch of off
policyiness
in exchange for the ability to run
training at the same time as you're
running the env.
There is definitely a noticeable
degradation from async in many cases
though, which is why it's still a
prototype.
Yeah, Finn, I don't care if like what
the score says, this is a much better
run than before. Like this is
marketkedly better.
In fact, I would argue that having low
depth with a very high score is actually
a bad sign. If anything, that just shows
you that you're sitting there punching
stuff.
I mean, I could even consider negative
combat reward.
There are definitely some additional
metrics I would want to see like if we
solve a level of soabon.
We need we need to have some indicator
on
without adding a million of these little
metrics.
We need to have some sort of like
achievement fraction or something
like I want to know if it ever gets the
light stone. Getting the light stone. In
my mind, that would be like a hu uh the
luck stone would be a massive
achievement. Solving Soabon would be a
massive achievement. Actually, I don't
expect you to be able to solve so it
might learn to break all the boulders to
be fair.
That wouldn't be terrible if it just
learned to break all the boulders.
And then the big question, right, is if
it's if it's going to go for Minetown
every time or if it's going to be able
to come back and do the full dungeon.
Yes, of course, Finn.
And I think that you can write that in
your, you know, you can write that in
blog or whatever you want to do. But
once you've shown, okay, we crushed the
existing thing, then I think you're
allowed to make the point that the
existing thing was dumb and this is what
you should be optimizing, right?
like you want to optimize progress
through the game.
Note that you are actually when uh when
playing the game you are allowed to skip
the luck stone and you are allowed to
skip so
if it is simpler we could just give it a
big negative penalty for like you know
messing around in mine town or messing
around in so
if it's hard to learn backtracking and
just have it go straight down
the um
I think that the speedrun record
I think they mess around in mine town,
but I don't they don't do so.
They don't do luck stone.
I think they basically just go get a
pickaxe somewhere in mine town. They get
a few things that they need and then
they just dig straight down.
And there definitely some more stats I
want on here. I want to see wishes. Um,
if it gets a wish, we should absolutely
just hardcode what it should wish for.
Like seriously,
I don't know what the best wish for
wishes on a monk, but like blessed
greased gray dragon scale male plus two
if it were a valk.
I mean, that basically immediately lets
you play the game.
Before you get that, it's just like, uh,
can I actually fight things? But as soon
as you get that, you can just play the
game.
Yeah, glitzy. Nerups is annoying. I did
my time on that.
It's going to be tough, but I think we
need to we got to be able to at least be
pushing that hack to a mill SPS.
I think the model size is fine.
Realistically, I don't expect that we
need to try to push the model any
smaller.
I think the encoder we need to make more
efficient stuff.
DM to config.
Thank you.
It doesn't look like you've played with
this very much.
Gold coefficient is one. Wait, one. That
mean you get a reward per That's crazy,
isn't it?
I like that long horizon.
Longer horizon looks cool.
I'm going to take the liberty of
deleting these two coefficients.
Those
are basically never good.
It's funny that this doesn't um
whatever.
Oh, this is a chungus.
This is uh
It takes a while.
Not that bad.
Uh so big replay ratio is actually much
better with uh with async but you have
to stabilize it
for AC start. Gotcha.
Good starting AC then.
Do we have flags to just try other
characters by the way or no? I just like
flip it to Valk. See if it works.
Yeah, I kind of just got bored one day
and just tried it, Finn, and it like it
mostly works. It definitely makes stuff
faster, but there is a stability thing
to deal with.
The character choice is in net. Gotcha.
We'll mess with that next.
Do you have race settings?
Dwarven makes a big difference.
You're definitely a lot more dependent
though on like looking for armor.
Like you need to go out of your way to
like look for buck test armor, do a
bunch of stuff that probably the agent
doesn't know how to do.
Fully configurable.
All right, we'll see how this goes.
This is doing decently well so far
though
where do they get their AC from
primarily?
Well, obviously it's deterministic
proceed.
What do you mean?
Helms, boots, mines. Yeah.
What do you even wish for on a monk,
though?
AC scales with XP.
Should scale well.
Oh, that's funny. Look at this. It's
avoiding mine town. That's why it's
going deeper.
You see this?
So, it's on depth 8 86 or whatever,
but it's doing that
like just by avoiding the mind's branch.
People review papers with LMS too. Yes.
And some conferences have widely have
wisely decided to ban such people, but
unfortunately they still do.
I mean, I can see from this right that
it basically it hasn't gotten any
AC bonus
the whole run.
So
like Yeah. Ouch. Right.
Wait, how is death adjacent monsters
greater than one?
Oh, how many monsters are adjacent when
you die?
Okay.
Yeah. So, it's dying in combat
cuz it has no [ __ ] AC.
It's just yeeting all the way down
without getting any AC because it's a
monk.
So, I don't know if it wouldn't put
armor on if it could
Why the values so unusual? They're
chosen via protein. Protein is our
state-of-the-art hyperparameter sweep
algorithm.
Getting it to wear armor consistently is
hard.
I mean, I'm tempted to just run it with
a Valk and see if it figures it out.
What's What's happening?
reinforcement learning on Net Hack.
This uh this is Finn's project at the
moment and I am seeing if I can make any
little improvements to it.
I mean, I'm just kind of still getting a
sense for it. Um seeing where it's
failing,
you know, seeing what the thing is
messing up.
So, only specific stuff.
Specific cursed stuff.
Oh, no. You have a cursed item worn or
wielded.
We probably want the alignment
penalties.
Oh, and Monk is probably getting a ton
of alignment penalties as well because
it's just eating corpses
because it doesn't know any better.
Yeah, I mean looking at this, I wouldn't
be surprised that Valk ends up being
easier.
Let's give this a shot. So I mean this
is
I'm send this to Finn
is like this is a good result
and whiz.
Yeah, but like it doesn't scale, man.
Right.
I think you need to like go out of your
way to find a bunch of high enchant
stuff to compensate for not having a
body.
Where's this thing? You said net hack or
netlib.h maybe.
I see
agent.
Oh, okay. So,
wait, how do we do this?
Is it just Val?
foul dwar. Yeah. Okay. It's just like
this
All right. Let's see what happens.
Oops.
I just kill this
Why?
Why do they Why do people report episode
return? like
score
1K score in a billion steps.
Yeah. Okay.
Original baselines were very weak.
Okay, look. It's already reducing.
AC has gone down a fair bit. Now it's
tied with the monk's AC already.
Look at soul for score.
So this is super fancy method and just
kind of like gets wrecked.
Yeah. So, you more than double soda
their stupid fancy method with something
very simple.
You're not even using that many steps or
anything.
So, good job. Um, considering that
at least one of these two of these
Michaels are two of the best in the
field. So, good job on uh steamrolling.
I guess we'll compare once this
finishes. And this doesn't look bad to
me though, man.
also.
I thought we have reward clamping on
still.
We see wear on here. Yeah. Where?
Look, Finn. It's wearing armor.
Was it wearing armor before?
Uh, it's it's doing wear two or three
times as much already as before.
was doing less than one wear per episode
before.
So there you go. This seems to help.
Level seven already.
I mean for first run
we got 8.8 last time.
Hey, I just saw a net hack exited with
status message. Finn, does that mean
anything?
fixed earlier. Gotcha. Didn't kill the
run, so
when you get eaten by a worm and then
teleported.
Uh, this is the great thing about having
super fast Sims is just every possible
niche thing will happen.
I got to use that story for clients.
That's nuts. Oh yeah, we had a bug that
we found. It's when you get eaten by a
worm and then teleported.
Uh, you said Valk wasn't going well
before, but this looks fine to me, man.
Like,
this looks pretty good.
We're almost matching Monk already.
We don't have to worry about the stupid
vegetarian
annoyance.
Any progress on net hack? You're looking
at it.
Got here depth eight.
Um
score was very good. No longer
optimizing score though because score is
a very bad metric. Actually, it's
indicative of how much you're farming.
Dwarfven Valku might stomp mines. Yeah,
it totally will. Like, I think if you
wanted to get a luck stone, it would be
pretty cool if you log the luck stone
thing. I think we'll be able to get it
off of that just cuz you get so many
free. You just can run through the mines
with no issue.
At least the upper mines.
You can get very unlucky. Like I ran
into a vampire lord in the deeper mines
and I had to come back after so after a
wish with ray dragon scale male
in order to kill it.
The other annoying thing with Valk is
getting a weapon.
I don't have an amazing weapon.
like the spear is okay.
I mean, one other fun thing, like if we
just want to try a couple things, Finn,
we can see if we get a luck stone with
Valk and we can see if we ever get Excal
with uh with the knight, you know.
It'd have to learn to dip the long
sword, though. That's pretty unlikely.
You can do it pretty early, but you have
to learn to dip the uh long sword
and then it's still only like a one and
six, I think. So, you have to do it
quite a bit.
It's actually kind of funny how close
these runs are.
We got 3.5 AC per reference on monk last
time. So, the worst starting AC
is very quickly offset by you just
finding some armor.
selfplay policy for 10 bill steps only
to play 73.
Well, you definitely want to monitor if
you're actually improving over time.
Typically, straight selfplay is not
great. You need some sort of historical
selfplay. And then the tricky thing with
it's not the tricky thing is not that it
is imperfect information.
The tricky thing is that it's a freaking
self-play game. Um, where you have to
cover the strategy space.
So, anything you can get to like train
against more diverse opponents is
probably helpful.
It's actually one of the main things
we've been working on in Puffer lately
is figuring out a more general approach
to that cuz um, yeah, it's an annoying
setting. Imperfect information is just
no big deal though. And as long as you
have a standard the standard puffer net
with memory will do that just no
problem.
Like information perfect versus
imperfect information.
Um
it's a uh an academic or theoretical
distinction. In practice the things that
make problems hard are quite different
than that.
All right. We're going to get this
result in a second. And
it's slightly worse than Monk, but out
of the box, like this looks good to me.
I think Monk is kind of just only good
very early.
I have to ask with uh
I'll have to ask Ryan about that.
Buffer could play poker.
I mean, sure. And go ahead and train
one.
The difficulty with poker would be the
um
the selfplay
like different strategy coverage thing.
Uh, we're getting the net hack status
exit thing now a lot then
negative -4,000 some like negative44
something other code. I see a few
different exit codes. Yeah, we're
getting a lot of different exits here.
Well, this is um I don't think people
have done as well actually with Valk
before,
so
let's just send this. Boom.
I think for comparison, that's pretty
good. We were um one was it six uh 60%
of a level shallower. We ended with
basically the exact same min.
Uh we actually were a little bit more
efficient with it. We got slightly
shorter episodes to get there. And I'm
not really worried about the score
difference either.
I think that's like 100% good. That's
just good. Yeah.
Do this.
Async. I wanted to try Async. I don't
know if we're quite ready for that.
Let's see what this config looks like.
Very high prioritization
I wonder if just this config
does worse.
I really want to wait for this to run
for 15 minutes though.
We should have more intelligent things
we can figure out in the meantime,
right?
Yeah, we should definitely have more
intelligent things that we can figure
out.
So Finn, is the uh the monster encoding
when you see a monster, is it just like
a one hot over all the different
monsters
just M's resetting.
Why did I get spammed with it at the
end?
I have to figure out this obstructor? I
think
this separate masking like architecture
is a little nutty as well.
We'll definitely want to play with that.
[clears throat]
Yeah,
each is a factorized embedding.
I mean, this is the main thing I kind of
want to figure out right now then
because
can it actually tell when it's like
seeing a hard monster versus an easy
monster?
Like monsters have a difficulty on them.
Can we easily give it that
monster base level? I've tried giving
the embedding also a monster.
you are a lawful dwarfish.
Lawful dwarven Valkyrie. Okay.
There's no way. Look, Finn. Gold Co is
one and it's ignoring money.
There's no way this thing can see
like properly,
right?
There's no way you give this thing a
massive gold bonus and it's just not
picking up money.
Now it picks it up, but it could have
picked it up earlier. There.
We're net hacking, Jess. Or the agent is
net hacking.
Good question, Finn. Um,
I will double check, but this should be
carrying the state all the way through.
We'll see if this gets like similar
score though to what's expected.
or similar depth.
It is possible that the policies just
screwed up a little bit.
Like more than 2x crushed. Actually,
like 3x crushed, right?
With a way simpler method as well,
courtesy of the fin turn.
I'm I'm going to be honest. I might have
messed it up because this looks weird to
me.
Oh, hang on.
Oh, is that a shop? Yeah, it's a shop.
And it died.
Uh that died very early.
Just see if I screwed anything up on the
port.
Can run some quick checks
cuz I just want to watch.
I want to just watch the model and see
where it messes up.
I don't believe it's getting to depth
like 8 plus on average and is looking
that lost.
I'm going to think about the embeddings
as well.
It's not that I don't know what to do
here. It's just that there's a lot of
like
it's difficult to try things because
there's a bunch of code.
needs to kind of get cleaned up a
Oh, okay. Maybe we're using the wrong
weights. Hang on. I think we're probably
using the wrong weights.
I'm sure it's going to mess up some like
stuff that it shouldn't be even
touching. We'll have to uh figure that
out.
Want to make sure we get this thing set
up nicely. Oh yeah, I'm also going to
fix the rendering, man. Or I'll have
Grock fix the rendering, whichever.
We need to actually have this thing show
like proper net hack.
Want to see the whole inventory. I want
to see like colors on the uh the
creatures. There's
Let's see if this policy looks stupid
still.
it's Look at this [ __ ] It reward hacks
gold pickup.
It just kicked the gold to split the
stack so that it can get rewarded for
each stack.
[laughter]
That's [ __ ] amazing.
Hey, whoever's on YouTube or you Tw like
can somebody just clip that please?
Like clip that and post. That's [ __ ]
amazing. Holy.
That's one of the coolest reward hacks
I've ever seen.
I think as well it's probably like we
still have the reward clamping. I'm
pretty sure.
Okay, there it goes. Now it figured it
out.
Okay, it didn't do it again. It just did
it again. Look at that. You see, it
kicks it. So it can pick up more gold.
Look at that.
Kick, kick, kick. It's not a oneoff.
Look at that. Look at all the gold it's
making.
Kick, kick, kick.
It literally just doesn't even care. It
probably just wants to go deeper to find
more gold to kick. Look at this.
What are we hitting the fog cloud for?
Okay, we're fine.
How are we dealing with this?
Okay, we're just going to go down.
We scatter gold.
Net hack, how's it going so far? Uh,
soda by more than a factor of two.
Entirely thanks to Finn.
I'm helping Finn out a little bit now,
but I myself I have made no progress on
this so far today other than just like I
don't know some speed improvements. Oh,
this is Oracle level. I've mostly made
some speed improvements and kind of set
things up for more progress than I have
made actual progress.
Here's your Oracle.
Oh, did we did we just pray? We did. I
thought we were dead. We were dead, but
we just prayed. Cool. So, we're level
four now.
I think we're dead here. Yeah. So, we
just died to killer bees. Didn't have
enough AC. We're kind of too lowleveled
to be on that floor.
What's the SPS
I think like 400k or something.
Well, this one's slower. This one's like
200 something thousand.
But this is sort of a weird config.
So, I think realistically it tops out
around 4 to 500k right now.
I think with like quite a bit of
optimization work, we can probably get
this to a millionish.
The annoying thing is that's using all
of the cores.
So, um, you know, even on an 8GPU box,
we wouldn't be able to get it much
faster,
barring like major improvements to the
net hack force, which apparently Finn's
already messed with.
I mean, that's such a cool reward hack,
though. Look at this. It kicks the gold
to try to like make piles out of it
because we give it a big reward for
gold.
Watch.
See? Come on. Find some more gold. Do
it.
What did Finn do? Finn's been working on
this for a few weeks now.
I mean, he's got like the pure He's got
nice bindings. He's made improvements to
um the whole like perf everywhere
and cudinet.
Big changes to observations.
I didn't even know pass could spawn like
that. That's interesting.
But I have this rigged up right now just
so uh if I hold space it just advances.
So the network plays when I just hold
space.
I think this is better than just letting
it autoplay because if if anything weird
happens, I can just let go of space and
look at it.
Wait, did we go back to Delve level two?
We did.
Wait, we backtracked.
Huh,
that was cool.
Hey, this policy is actually pretty
good.
I mean, I would say this is like a
reasonable
result out of puffer liib. No.
Like, we're exploring a bit.
Yeah. Yeah. It went into the mines and
then it came back up. Apparently, it
doesn't like the mines.
I don't know what reward combination
this is that makes it not like the
mines. There's kicking gold.
So, got the gold.
Run del level four.
Look at that. We're just kicking gold.
Farming reward.
How complex is Net Hack? The most
ludicrously [ __ ] complex game you've
ever heard of.
It puts almost all modern games to
shame.
If you try to just play the game like
off the bat, you'll just you'll
essentially just get railed over and
over and over until you go watch at
least five hours of videos or like read
several dozen pages of the wiki
or both.
Okay. It's actually really good at
finding hidden passages.
Like it knows when there's supposed to
be an entrance there. I think
there it's reward farming for gold.
Red Naga hatchling and paper golem.
How are we gonna play this? Elberth.
Yeah, Elth. We We engrave Elbert here.
Why are we chasing them?
Apparently, it works. We kill it.
Huh.
I wouldn't have played it that way, but
it worked.
this is Soaban right here.
So, we found Soaban.
Are we going to do Soaban?
No, we're not going to do Soaban.
There's no way in hell it figures out.
I messed up like four times trying to do
it. They're not easy so levels.
Okay, so we don't go to Soaban for some
reason.
Gold co is one, so it gets clamped.
Yeah, exactly, Finn.
Exactly.
Now you get it.
Okay, look at this
quivering blob.
Look at that. It's just kicking all the
gold around. Yay. Reward.
This is an interesting level
architecture.
Actually,
shouldn't it be able to infinitely farm
reward just by dropping? I think
actually if it learns to drop its gold
stack and kick it around, it would have
an infinite reward farm
with the uh the current thing. But it
probably just doesn't know how to do
that. Or yeah,
we are on level 11 now.
I've I didn't even cherry pick. This is
the second roll out I've watched of this
policy.
Uh we're probably dead here though,
right?
It probably is going to run phase for
first into this. Well, let's get the
screenshot now before it inevitably does
that.
and we yeet away.
Wait, is the thing smart?
We're about to get clapped by a
minotaur.
Yeah, that's what I expected.
And
did we just pray?
I think we prayed, but I think we're
still dead.
Yeah, we just got wrecked.
Well,
I mean, that's pretty good.
Like,
Uh, Finn, now is when I would expect
that you actually need the difficulty
embedding for uh the mobs. By the way,
I don't think that it understood what it
was getting itself into there.
[sighs and gasps] That is awesome,
though. That's a good policy. Damn.
I sent uh I sent Ryan the screenshot
like, "Hey, look what I found." He's
like, "Oh, nice. You're like doing well
with Net Hack." He said, "I lied. This
is the agent.
Okay. Well, it had AC6.
It needs to not
It needs to not have AC6
first and foremost.
I didn't
I didn't see whether any armor was
dropped,
but I mean,
I'd be pretty shocked if it was not
dropped some armor
to put on during that entire thing.
I'm trying to think what is the best I
could do at Net Hack without access to
all the buttons, like without access to
inventorying stuff.
If I were just going to like run around
and hit things,
I set it to one
and so that's
it. It does learn to equip things like
we have
in the stats it says that it does
occasionally equip things.
I think it still has a tough time with
the action space. I'm a little bit
sketched out by the way that you have
the masked spaces working
because
you essentially have it at the moment
where like it picks an option for
quaing,
eating, wield. It picks an option for
everything, but then the only one that
gets executed is the actual action.
Where's that paper that I sent you?
Let's take a look at it.
So, let's see.
No masking.
Nice way to do it. Yeah, I think this is
the
I think I can leave this to you to
implement, right, Finn?
cuz this is the next thing I would
probably mess with.
So you already have the pointer net
thing, right?
So presumably this simplifies stuff a
little bit
pointer net. Yeah. Okay. Well, I think
then you have what to do with that. That
plus the difficulty thing.
Let me just run one last one last thing.
that and then
and then we'll run one more small Okay.
Okay, there we go. That's the sub one
second breakout solve. So, uh, it
exists. I'll show it again.
One second.
I just wanted to make sure I didn't
break anything in the process.
Breakout's a nice way to test it because
it's super fast.
See if async works now.
Be nice if it did
because this would play very well with
the replay ratio.
15 minutes.
I guess we'll see.
Trying to think if there's any other
good advice I can give.
really doesn't get penalized that much
for dying.
It's tough. You don't want it to yeet
all the way down, right?
It's supposed to explore a bit in order
to get like some armor and stuff.
So, part of that is the reward function
and then part of that is the action
space just being hard to use, I'd say.
Oh yeah, the lux like a couple of the
metrics Finn. Um
I think that if you get like the got
luck stone or whatever.
See if we can get the luck stone once
even.
I think that'd be a nice thing. Now, the
problem with that is, of course, then
you're kind of stuck at the bottom of
the mines and you got to go back up or
whatever
depth.
Uh, you don't want to you don't want to
sweep against something that sparse
unless it has some signal.
So, you can just have like deeper and
deeper thing that you sweep against, I
guess,
but you don't want something on zero.
The problem with the mines and like deep
mines is um
you don't technically need to do them
and I think you have to backtrack a lot
if you do.
I think depth is kind of fine.
I actually have no idea how you have a
config that like prevents them from
going to mine town. It's kind of crazy.
like it just goes to Soabon and it just
ignores it or like Mine Town and it
ignores it. So, there's something with
the rewards that's having it do that.
It's not a bad thing actually. Um, not
necessarily.
If we could get it to go to Minetown and
then backtrack, that would be way better
because there are a lot of shops in
Minetown. But, you know, obviously it
has to use learn to use shops and stuff.
Then
It's also very odd to me that like the
amount of times it dies by getting
smited.
like it doesn't die to starvation, which
is a very common cause of death for new
players.
It basically just gets
alter use would be cool.
Yeah,
I mean you can make it easier, right?
Like the alter action would just be like
dx like dot space or something. Just
drop all your items on the altar. Like
drop all the unknown status on that.
That makes sense.
I mean, I actually was thinking, right,
like even if it's just equipping random
curse stuff,
that's kind of dumb if you know how to
use an altar, but it's not that bad in
the scheme of things cuz you can pray,
right?
Oh, actually, hey, is Jess still here?
Cuz this is what we would want for uh
for chess as well.
This is exactly what we would want for
chess.
Actually, I I'll just add both of you in
the Um
there.
Uh, conditional action tree. Jess, this
is probably the way to do chess,
I would say. And, uh, Finn will try this
out in net hack.
So,
I'll put it in, uh, I'll put it in the
the channel,
put it in dev.
This experiment unfortunately looks like
a failure. This is me running it with
async.
At the very least for async we'd have to
reweep I would think.
It is actually interesting if you look
at this though we are at 400k SPS
and the end of is no longer a major
problem right
getting async working would be quite
major
I I'll see if I can get a a sweep on
this.
That'd be nice.
Oh,
let me delete this.
Why Why does it not like I'm following
you, right?
I am following you. Why the [ __ ] is this
like search so [ __ ]
that it doesn't go like it just pulls up
random people instead of
wait I was f what? All right now I'm
following you. That's bizarro.
I'm also going to move the net hack
policy out of source. I think
I might just like move the policies like
the custom policies into ocean or
whatever.
All right. So, this is catastrophic
failure. So, async does not work out of
the box. That's fine.
You can do whatever is more comfortable
for you. in 5C has some really cool
stuff in it, but it's still like a lot
to fix. I mean, the cool thing with 5C,
this is the entirety of the like this is
all of Puffer Lib now. And if I, you
know, if you just get rid of this from
the line count, this is only 12K lines.
It's really tight.
I'm still working on cleaning stuff up,
though.
All
Do I want to spin up a vast box for
this?
Would think so, right?
Oh, actually wait.
This thing's going to be kind of a piece
of [ __ ] to sweep, isn't it?
AMD
64 core.
Sweep ranges. I'll check them. We
automat There auto checks on that as
well. No.
Do pull in latest patch.
What do you mean latest? Doesn't the
latest NLE patch that just gets applied
if uh if I build it fresh, doesn't it?
Or
what patch?
Oh no, I'm leaking my public key on
stream. Guys,
whatever shall we
This is my favorite part, actually. Look
at this. Boop. Goodbye, Python.
We also don't need this.
And that's super funny.
Python 312D dev.
Who would want that garbage?
Look how clean that is.
Oh, you imbecile.
Wait. Huh? Why is this?
The space at the end screws it. Really?
That's a bizarre one.
Extra space screws it.
I I'm not understanding this.
I install packages and then packages are
not installed.
That's
Wait, is this dash V?
Oh, hang on.
got to love. Why do we need Python to
build net hack?
Uh, that would be a thing to fix as
well. We should not need [ __ ] Python
to build net hack.
Ideally, we'd like to not even have to
worry about Python at
See this whole pi binding thing can get
deleted.
We'll just do
have eight threads.
You can sweep whatever cos you want.
4 E8.
One E9 is good.
5 E8.
don't really want to be sweeping
literally everything here,
but we'll comment the policy.
We're fine there.
I think. But we're going to want to
restrict it a little bit. Maybe
let's say
128 up until
four
Everything else is probably okay.
I already got rid of the crap ones.
And I was going to sweep
I was going to sweep async one, right?
Yeah, I was going to sweep it with async
one.
to start
first. We'll make sure that trains
just setting up a sweep just
This will actually tell me
uh default But
Um,
it would be a
oneoff change experimentally for now,
Jess. And if it's broadly useful, we'd
integrate it broadly.
That's fine. It's allowed to fail. It's
allowed to fail runs like that.
It'll probably spam some prints like
this.
But the important thing
Oh,
hang on.
There we are.
You see we have
stuff going.
And
why are GPUs
Why Why are these GPUs not doing [ __ ]
Hello.
use my GPU.
This is just a vast box, man.
You can rent these for four or five
bucks an hour.
Okay. So then this is
this is just [ __ ] for me to fix.
It'll be worth uh relaunching for this
as well, annoying enough.
it should. I have more refactors to do,
of course.
I think I'm going to end stream after
this.
I just want to make sure we got this the
um
we've started, you know,
this is fine. It's allowed to um
to do this.
should see all the GPUs nicely loaded.
Well, not nicely loaded. Very [ __ ]
utilization cuz net hack is low. If we
look at the core count,
well, we can see the CPU on max
everything right
up.
All right,
I'm going to call it here. End of
implementation. Yeah. Uh Finn made some
improvements to just the speed, not like
logic changes. Net hacks SPS on 32
cores. Uh on my box, we can peak between
four and 500,000 SPS training with a
reasonable config.
And I do think that it is relatively
feasible for us to get to a million. It
will take quite a bit of optimization,
but I think we can get a million. The
big issue though is that's using all the
cores. Uh, and you really for sweeps,
you only can afford to use eight cores
per GPU.
So, we will see.
Anyways though, I think that's good for
today. I'll probably do a little bit
more refactoring or whatnot, but other
than that, I am uh I am set for now. So,
thank you very much for tuning in,
folks. Once I've finished all these
refactors, there'll probably be some
more streams relatively soon. Puffer.ai
for all the things. Start the puffer on
GitHub to support helps me out a lot.
It's absolutely free. And uh if you'd
like to get involved with the project
building environments or oncore research
or whatnot, it's all open source. Run
everything through the Discord. So just
drop in there and ask